الأمير هاري وزوجته والسيدة الأخرى
كانوا متوترين وبدا
خائفين
[موسيقى]
أرى ثلاثة أشخاص يقفزون من
سيارة سوداء مباشرة إلى سيارتي وكان الأمير
هاري وميغان وكان
معهم أيضًا امرأة أخرى
و  ثم بينما كنا نتقدم بشكل مستقيم ، وبينما كنا نتجه
مباشرة ، كانت
شاحنة القمامة تمنعنا ، كان
يجمع القمامة ،
وخرج كل المصورون فجأة من العدم
وبدأوا في التقاط الصور ، واه كما تعلمون
ولم يتوقفوا حتى
نزل الأمن وقالوا تحركوا
ثم نزلت شاحنة القمامة من
الطريق وكان المصورون يتابعون
السيارة والأمير هاري وزوجته
والسيدة الأخرى كانوا متوترين وبدا أنهم
خائفون من
الأجانب
[موسيقى]
كانت مشاعرهم طبيعية لكنني متأكد من أن
مشاعرهم كانت أكثر حدة لأنه
أه لأمه ماتت الأميرة ديانا في
حادث تحطم وهي تهرب من
المصورين لذا أعتقد أن عواطفهم
كانت ضحكات أعلى
[تصفيق]